trust the Lakers were doubling James is
all about you tonight attacking the
basket good enough 41 how much fun is
that when everybody is playing so
efficiently and it's such a well-rounded
basketball on offense it's great to do
we came in to compete at a high level
defensively for the most part you guys
made some big moves at the deadline
Robert Covington played minutes for the
first time tonight what was your
thoughts on his fit in this rotation
he's amazing man kokin defend at a high
level
shoot the heck out of the basketball as
you did tonight man and I'm just happy
on our team cuz I gotta ask you being
from the LA area I know you're emotional
this whole past two weeks because the
passing of Kobe and he was close with
you he put up 41 was that for him
tonight and what did it mean to be on
this court right now I mean it's a
blessing man I don't take none of this
game for granted and Kobe was a mentor a
friend brother to me and every time I
stopped when this was definitely going
out to him the rest of my basketball
career and every every every night I
step on the floor man I just keep my
thoughts and prayers with him and it's
family and I gotta compete thanks for
sharing and congrats on the win dress